أصدر عمدة مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس
لقطات من كاميرا جسدية تظهر
نائبًا وهو يلكم أمًا بينما كانت تحمل
طفلها البالغ من العمر ثلاثة أسابيع أثناء
توقف حركة المرور العام الماضي، أنا أم
يقول الشريف إن النواب أوقفوا السيارة
لقيادتها بدون
يقول النواب إنهم
يستطيعون شم رائحة الكحول في السيارة أثناء تشغيل المصابيح الأمامية وأثناء التوقف، ويقول
النواب إنه كان هناك ثلاثة أطفال رضع في
السيارة تحتجزهم أمهاتهم غير
مثبتين في مقعد سيارة الطفل،
ونتيجة لذلك، اعتقل النواب المرأة بتهمة
تعريض الأطفال للخطر وكذلك  يمكن رؤية السائق
الذي تم القبض عليه أيضًا لقيادته
برخصة موقوفة والقيادة تحت
تأثير
السكر خلال مقطع الفيديو الذي تبلغ مدته ثماني دقائق ونصف، لأول مرة وهو يتحدث إلى
امرأة تجلس على الأرض لمدة
ست دقائق تقريبًا من الفيديو الذي حاولوه
دون جدوى  لإقناع المرأة
بمنحهم الرضيع عن طيب خاطر، يمكنك
إما تسليمها الطفل أو يمكنك المشي
فوق تلك السيارة هناك ووضع
الطفل في مقعد السيارة لنا النواب،
ثم يستخدم ما وصفه الشريف
بأنه استخدام للقوة  قم بإلقاء القبض على المرأة
والسيطرة على الأطفال،
لدينا حسنًا، حسنًا، ستمسك بالطفل، هل
يمكنكم يا رفاق الانتظار، الانتظار، لا الاستماع، من فضلكم أوه نعم،
أنتم ستنجبون الطفل من فضلكم، من فضلكم
دعوني أتمسك به لمدة دقيقتين إضافيتين
من فضلكم
[موسيقى]
لا لا لا لا من فضلك من فضلك من فضلك من فضلك من فضلك من فضلك،
فيديو كاميرا الجسم ثم يظهر
النواب وهم يتحدثون إلى امرأة ثانية
ويطلبون منها أن تعطيهم الرضيع الذي
تحمله
بعد أقل من دقيقتين وفقا
للعمدة، قام أحد النواب بلكم
المرأة مرتين في وجهها  وبينما كانت
تحمل طفلها البالغ من العمر ثلاثة أسابيع،
وجدت أن لكم المرأة في
هذه الظروف
غير مقبول على الإطلاق، وقد وجهت
قسم المعايير المهنية لدينا
بإحالة هذا الحادث إلى
مكتب المدعي العام للمنطقة للنظر فيه جنائيًا،
كما سينظر مكتب مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي في لوس أنجلوس.
في هذه المسألة التي
وصفتها، أخبر الشريف الصحفيين
أن النائب المعني لم يعد موجودًا في
الميدان ولكن بسبب قانون الولاية،
قال إنه لا يستطيع أن يوضح أكثر من ذلك،
وقال أيضًا إن تصرفات
الضباط الآخرين في مكان الحادث قيد المراجعة
وقال قسم الشريف إن المرأة
نُقلت إلى مستشفى محلي بسبب
شكوى من أنها تعاني من الألم